en estos momentos que ya sabemos que es
una matriz pues sería muy bueno aprender
también cómo se multiplican las matrices
por escalares así que primero me voy a
tomar una matriz y la voy a multiplicar
por un escalar y van a saber ustedes
también que es un escalar tomemos la
matriz 75 menos 10 y abajo 3 8 y 0 esta
matriz de dos filas y tres columnas la
voy a multiplicar por el número 3 como
podemos definir esta operación lo
primero que voy a definir es este número
3 este número 3 se le conoce como un
escalar es un número real que está
afuera de una matriz un numerito como
nosotros lo conocemos y este número está
afuera de la matriz por lo tanto cómo va
a afectar mi matriz o cómo voy a definir
la multiplicación por un número
cualquiera pero bueno antes que nada
vamos a ponerle el nombre ya este número
3 lo vamos a bautizar con el nombre de
escalar y ahora sí vamos a ver que nos
sale o cómo podemos definir la
multiplicación de 3 por toda esta matriz
como creen ustedes que se pueda definir
esta operación
la respuesta de esta pregunta es la
siguiente lo único que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar este 3 por cada una de las
entradas de esta matriz así de fácil y
así de sencillo es decir que para cada
uno de los numeritos que tenemos adentro
de esta matriz vamos a multiplicarlo por
este número 3 por este escalar que está
afuera por lo tanto pues vamos a hacerlo
va a multiplicar a cada una de las
entradas es decir 3 por 7 3 por 5
después a la siguiente entrada también
va a ser multiplicada por 3 3 por menos
10 3 por 3
después seguiría 3 por 8 y para
finalizar 3 por 0 y bueno ya que tenemos
esto podemos resolver esta operación
esto es muy sencillo porque ya tenemos
que las operaciones correspondientes que
vamos a hacer ahorita ya están en los
números reales y ya están en cada una de
las entradas 3 por 7 21 en la entrada de
en medio de esta primera fila tenemos 15
después tenemos menos 33 por 3 393 por 8
24 y 3 por 0 es cero y así definimos
esta operación es multiplicar simple y
sencillamente
escalar por cada una de las entradas de
esta matriz